[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à quel moment est ce que chacune d'entre
vous a pris conscience de la différence
de traitement entre hommes et femmes et
des difficultés qu'on a tout à s'imposer
dans la sphère publique
ayant grandi dans un environnement très
féminin un papa décédé quand j'avais 7
ans deux grandes soeurs une école de
filles jusqu'en terminale
j'en ai pris conscience très tardivement
et paradoxalement je pense que ça m'a au
contraire aider parce que je n'ai pas
été confrontée finalement à cette
différence de traitement à l'école par
exemple en est loin de me décourager ça
m'a stimulé
quand je me suis retrouvé en classes
préparatoires dans un environnement
cette fois-ci hyper masculin ça m'a
stimulé
ça m'a donné envie d'en découdre
pourquoi parce que je pense que j'avais
réellement acquis confiance en moi au
cours des années la confiance en soi
je pense que c'est la condition
préalable pour que la femme réussissent
à s'imposer aujourd'hui dans la sphère
publique
mais est-ce que c'est du domaine de
l'inné et de l'acquis
j'ai toujours eu confiance en moi j'ai
toujours envie de me dépasser
montrer que je voulais être aussi bonne
que les garçons tant sur un plan
intellectuel que sportif et quand
j'avais 15 ans j'ai été vice championne
de france de monoski donc j'ai toujours
eu envie de me battre c'est j'ai
toujours eu envie voilà d'aller d'aller
plus loin et en même temps je pense
qu'on a tous un moment un événement
fondateur qui va faire qu'on va avoir
confiance en soi et qu'on va ancrer
cette confiance pour le reste de sa vie
le mien c'était à 17 ans quand je me
suis retrouvé en classe préparatoire à
pasteur à neuilly alors que je rêvais de
faire ma classe prépa à gillett à
versailles et malheureusement je n'avais
pas été prise et bien qu'est ce qui
s'est passé je me suis dit que j'allais
réussir à convaincre le directeur de
l'école de me prendre alors que la
rentrée avait déjà eu lieu
j'en ai même pas parlé à ma mère j'ai
pris le rer et je suis allé à ginette
pour essayer de rencontrer le directeur
et ça a marché il m'a prise et moi ça ça
a été mon événement fondateur
ça a été la chose qui va ancrer qui m'a
donné confiance en moi
et c'est quoi vous votre événement
fondateur c'est quoi le moment où vous
vous êtes dit vous les femmes que vous
pouvez avoir confiance en vous mais la
confiance en soi c'est pas uniquement
c'est aussi 2 c'est aussi de la quille
et l'éducation elle joue un rôle clé et
malheureusement en france
je trouve que l'éducation elle donne pas
vraiment confiance aux enfants on a par
exemple très peu d'apprentissage de la
prise de parole en public et c'est
dommage je vais vous donner un autre
exemple il ya des études qui ont montré
que quand on donnait un exercice de
maths à une classe de filles en leur
disant qu traditionnellement elles
réussissent mieux cet exercice que les
garçons le taux de succès il est de
l'ordre de 72 %
maintenant on prend le même exercice
une autre classe témoins deux filles et
on leur dit qu'elles réussissent moins
bien cet exercice que les garçons et
bien le taux de succès passe à 58%
pourquoi parce que la plasticité de
notre cerveau fait qu'il est extrêmement
sensible à l'environnement extrêmement
sensible aux messages qui sont transmis
est ce que ça veut pas dire qu'il faut
mettre en place peut-être certaines
inégalités certaines différences pour
arriver à créer les conditions de
légalité
peut-être peut-être que par exemple à
l'école dans certaines tranches d'âge
peut-être qu'il faudrait pas mélanger
les filles et des garçons moi j'ai pas
de réponse là dessus mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est qu'en tant que mère de
quatre enfants dont trois filles sont
ici présentes
j'estime que j'ai un rôle à jouer pour
donner confiance pour stimuler la
confiance de mes enfants
et c'est vrai pour vous aussi vous soyez
parent de filles ou de garçons on a un
rôle à jouer maintenant en entreprise
comment est ce qu'on fait pour également
donné confiance
après la revente de mille et une liste
en 2006 je me suis passionné pour les
sujets autour de la diversité j'ai
rejoint le women's forum qui avait été
créée par aude de thuin
j'ai rencontré beaucoup de patrons
emblématiques en particulier dans
l'industrie qui avait construit qui
avait compris que pour instaurer une
certaine forme d'égalité dans leur
entreprise
il fallait peut-être accepté de mettre
en place certaines inégalités
je vais vous donner trois exemples le
premier ça concerne la gestion des hauts
potentiels
peut-être qu'il faut pas forcément les
prendre exactement dans la même tranche
d'âge parce que la femme aurait eu par
exemple un congé maternité
autre exemple
l'expatriation souvent on va dire aux
femmes qu'il faut qu'elle fait un
passage obligé à l'étranger pour pouvoir
prendre un poste à responsabilité c'est
aussi un critère qui peut être
défavorable aux femmes
et si on prend l'exemple des salaires la
femme les études le montrent va -
réclamer des augmentations de salaire
que les hommes et le patron un rôle à
jouer pour rééquilibrer tout ça moi j'ai
le cas inverse mon à une fois j'avais eu
une augmentation de salaire moindre
qu'un collègue je m'étais plainte et on
m'avait dit bah écoute ta mwen éclat
mais voilà donc je trouve que les
patrons ils ont un rôle clé à jouer et
peut-être qu'il faut qu'ils mettre en
place quelques inégalités de traitement
si je puis dire pour créer les
conditions d'égalité toujours à l'époque
du women's forum j'avais travaillé avec
gérard mestrallet suez
il avait mis en place énormément
d'initiatives de cet ordre là et on en
voit aujourd'hui les fruits avec la
nomination d'une femme à la tête de la
seule femme à la tête d'une entreprise
du cac 40 en france il avait été jusqu à
communiquer dans la presse sur ses
initiatives à montrer des femmes à des
postes masculin ce qui veut dire qu'on
peut même aller jusqu'à sortir le sujet
du pré carré de l'entreprise et le
mettre sur la place publique
mais là il faut que le patron il soit
réellement investi comment est ce qu'on
fait maintenant
pour également donner confiance aux
femmes dans les lieux publics dans les
dents le dire les lieux comme les
centres commerciaux qui est un sujet que
je connais bien puisque j'ai dirigé le
marketing du groupe unibail pendant cinq
ans en fait on s'est aperçu qu'il
fallait mettre des femmes dans les
équipes de conception et de design des
centres parce que en fait on s'est rendu
compte que quand on sait qu'elles ont
des sens qui sont plus développées je
prends l'exemple de louis de l'odorat si
je prends le parking du parking pour les
femmes c'est un lieu qui est toujours
considéré comme oxygène
ça sent mauvais on se sent pas bien
c'est vraiment un lieu on n'est pas en
sécurité parce qu'on avait fait à
l'époque on avait par exemple développer
une musique particulièrement rassurante
on avait développé une gamme de parfums
on avait également créé des codes
couleurs on avait effet créé une
ambiance qui fait que les femmes
allaient être rassurés allez prendre
confiance en elles et pas se sentir en
insécurité est dans la même logique dans
les centres commerciaux on a développé
des des espaces de repos par exemple
agréable où la femme a envie de
s'installer de rester où elle se sent
bien on va développer des attentions
avec par exemple un voiturier
on va mettre en place plein
d'initiatives pour que la femme ait
envie d'aller dans ces lieux de vie mais
pas qu'eux y aller mais qu'elle ait
aussi envie d'y rester qu'elle soit
seule ou à quelle soit avec des amis ou
avec des enfants et maintenant
l'entreprise responsable
elle peut aussi jouer un rôle pour
donner confiance aux femmes en levant
permettant de s'investir sur des sujets
sur lequel elles vont avoir une
sensibilité autres il ya deux ans et
demi j'ai monté un site d'entr'aide qui
s'appelle web
w es p c'est un site qui met en relation
des gens qui veulent se rendre des
services bénévoles et j'ai toute une
dimension en be to be autour de
l'engagement des salariés dans la
politique de responsabilité sociétale de
l'entreprise
très vite je me suis rendu compte que
plus de 70% des utilisateurs du web
étaient des femmes
pourquoi parce que la femme
naturellement avait elle va aller plus
vers l'autre elle va être dans cette
démarche citoyenne et bien l'entreprise
citoyenne justement celle qui est
responsable
celle qui va mettre en place une
politique de responsabilité sociétale en
cohérence avec ses valeurs elle a tout
intérêt à aller dans cette direction
elle peut donner plus de place aux
femmes elle peut leur donner confiance
en leur permettant de s'investir sur des
sujets qui sont pas uniquement d'ordre
professionnel mais également d'ordre
sociétal et quand on sait que le gain
moyen d'une entreprise qui est engagée
en matière de rse est de l'ordre de 13%
elle a intérêt à aller dans cette
direction en conclusion ce que j'ai
envie de vous dire c'est que la
confiance je suis convaincu que c'est
vraiment la condition c'est ce qui va
permettre aux femmes de s'imposer dans
la sphère publique et que pour créer ce
climat de confiance
peut-être qu'il faut accepter un moment
donné de mettre en place quelques
inégalités que ce soit dans la façon
dont on va élever nos enfants que ce
soit à l'école que ça soit dans la façon
dont on manage en entreprise ou dont on
va concevoir les espaces publics
mais la femme elle peut aussi agir
et quand elle a confiance en elle elle
va être capable justement d'agir et de
s'engager alors moi j'ai envie de vous
dire eh bien écoutez aujourd'hui toutes
les femmes
engageons-nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]